hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live schön dass ihr wieder mit
dabei seid wir sind wieder live und zwar
weil es aktuelle Meldungen aus Russland
gibt dort ist offenbar ein Flugzeug
abgestürzt und mit an Bord dieses
Flugzeugs soll eine ziemlich prominente
Person gewesen sein und zwar ifgeni
Pregarten der Chef der russischen
Söldnertruppe Wagner wir haben auch
schon aktuelle Bilder vorliegen aus
Russlands die seht ihr jetzt diese
Bilder sollen die Absturzstelle zeigen
es gibt mehrere Augenzeugen die
berichten dass diese Maschine kurz nach
dem Start explodiert ist und dann
abgestürzt ist insgesamt zehn Personen
sollen dabei uns Leben gekommen sein
unter anderem wie gesagt wir gehen der
Chef der russischen Söldnertruppe und
man muss dazu aber auch noch sagen diese
Bilder die jetzt gerade gesehen habt die
machen den sozialen Netzwerken die Runde
willifiziert sind sie bisher nicht sie
sollen aber wie gesagt die Absturzstelle
des Flugzeugs zeigen
was wir dazu jetzt aktuell Wissen
darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
meinem Kollegen Armin Körper er ist
Korrespondent für uns in Moskau und
jetzt zugeschaltet guten Abend Armin
danke dass du dir so schnell die Zeit
nimmst
hallo aus Moskau Ami bring uns bitte
gerne einmal kurz auf den aktuellen
Stand was ist bisher über diesen Absturz
des Flugzeugs bekannt
genau wir wissen noch nicht wirklich
viel man kann sich das so vorstellen
hier kommen jetzt natürlich permanent
Bestätigungen Meldungen Mutmaßungen und
Spekulationen ich versuche das mal so
ein bisschen zu sortieren also die
russische Luftfahrtbehörde hat unter
Berufung auf das Ministerium für
Katastrophenschutz bestätigt dass eine
Maschine abgestürzt ist gegen 17:40 Uhr
deutscher Zeit eine Maschine vom Typ
embrya Legacy 600 es handelt sich dabei
um einen Privatjet an Bord sollen zehn
Personen gewesen sein inklusive
Besatzung Design alle ums Leben gekommen
bisher geborgen wurden wohl acht Leichen
identifiziert wurde noch niemand laut
der Passagierliste befand sich an Bord
ein Passagier Namen
von der wagnergruppe ist hat bisher
niemand bestätigt
gemutmaßt wird in Telegramm Kanälen die
der wagnergruppe nahe stehen das auch an
Bord gewesen sei laut Passagierliste äh
Dimitri utkin das war ein alter
Kampfgefährte von pregorian und so ein
bisschen seine rechte Hand bei Wagner
das ist offiziell nicht bestätigt es
geht jetzt natürlich viel um die Frage
was ist da passiert was wissen wir über
die Ursache dieses Flugzeugabsturzes
offiziell ist dazu gar nichts gesagt
worden von offizieller Seite wurde eine
Kommission ein oder eine offizielle
Kommission hat verkündet dass
Ermittlungen eingeleitet werden in den
sozialen Netzwerken und russische
experten mutmaßen jetzt da ist einmal
die Vermutung es könnte eine Explosion
an Bord gegeben haben die den Absturz
verursacht hat andere mutmaßen es könnte
sich ein um einen Abschied durch eine
Luftabwehrrakete handeln da gibt's aber
wirklich sehr unterschiedliche
Informationen und Mutmaßungen
Informationen eigentlich noch gar keine
ein interessantes Detail ist dieses
Unglück ereignet sich auf den Tag genau
zwei Monate nachdem die gossin mit
seinen Wagner sollten dann die russische
Militärführung herausgefordert hat in
Form eines Putsches der ja dann kurz vor
den Toren Moskau eingestellt wurde
du sagst es die Informationslage ist
noch sehr dünn gibt es denn bisher schon
Reaktionen aus dem Kreml hat Putin da in
irgendeiner Form schon drauf reagiert
die Informationslage ist dünn
gleichzeitig ist es ungewöhnlich dass
zum Beispiel diese Behörde um die
Tageszeit so schnell Bestätigungen
rausgibt das ist schon ungewöhnlich aus
dem Krimml hört man überhaupt nichts
Präsident Putin war im Fernsehen zu
sehen live genau während dieses
Flugzeugabsturzes wie er
Veteranen einer Schlacht aus dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg geehrt hat es handelt sich um
die Schlacht von Kurs die aus Sowjet
oder aus russischer Sicht in der
sowjetischen Geschichtsschreibung als
eine der entscheidenden Schlachten im
Sieg über Nacht über Nazi Deutschland
angesehen wird da hat sich Präsident
Putin zu dem Zeitpunkt aufgehalten
gesagt hatte dazu überhaupt nichts
du hast es gerade schon angesprochen
dass dieser Absturz dieser mutmaßliche
Absturz jetzt genau zwei Monate auf den
Tag genau nach dem sozusagen privatin
aufgerufen hatte Richtung maska zu
marschieren mit den seltener Truppen
ist da war die gegenüber Putin schon
wieder rehabilitiert oder hatte Putin da
möglicherweise noch eine Rechnung im
Privaten
also wir haben uns ja alle sehr
gewundert Präsident Putin hat am Tag des
Putsches die Verursacher oder die die
Anführer dieses Putsches als Verräter
bezeichnet er hat gesagt die werden
verfolgt und wenige Stunden später
Sprache von Amnestie und hat die
eigentlich alle begnadigt nach Belarus
ziehen lassen und so weiter das ist ja
bekannt da hat man sich natürlich
gewundert wir wissen ja aus der
Vergangenheit wie der Kreml mit
mutmaßlichen Verrätern umgegangen ist
die wurden ja auf der ganzen Welt gejagt
das ist hier nicht passiert zumindest
bisher nicht wir haben immer wieder
gehört selten Bilder gesehen wir haben
aber immer wieder gehört dass pregorien
z.B im Kreml empfangen wurde es gab
Bilder von ihm vor einigen Wochen in St
Petersburg bei dem Russland Afrika
Gipfel da ist er öffentlich aufgetreten
da haben wir uns natürlich alle
gewundert wurde der Mann wirklich so
schnell rehabilitiert oder ist da noch
eine Rechnung offen
danke dir Armin Körper dass du das für
uns live aus Moskau beobachtest danke
für diese Information bis hierhin
es hat sich bisher dazu auch schon
geäußert der Politikwissenschaftler Nico
lange und Militärexperte den ihr hier
bei uns auch schon mal gehört habt und
zwar sagt er es wird jetzt viele geben
die sagen das ist ein Zufall oder das
ist ein Inszenierung aber ich glaube
dass vieles darauf hindeutet dass der
Mafia statt Russland mit Mafia Methoden
seine Probleme löst wir wollen uns das
ganze jetzt noch weiter einordnen lassen
und auch noch mal den Blick auf die
wagnertruppe und die Rolle von Pregarten
in der wagnertruppe und auch im Krieg
auf die Ukraine richten und ich freue
mich sehr dass wir dazu jetzt sprechen
können mit Andreas Heinemann grüder erst
Politikwissenschaftler an der Uni Bonn
und mir jetzt zugeschaltet hallo Herr
Hannemann Krüger danke für Ihre Zeit
guten Abend lassen Sie uns gerne einmal
mit der wagnertruppe einsteigen wer ist
diese Truppe
es ist eine irreguläre bewaffnete Gruppe
die im Umfeld des ersten Ukraine Krieges
2014/15 entstanden ist damals wollte
Russland ja immer noch abstreiten dass
sie selbst beteiligt sind die
sogenannten grünen Männchen auf der Krim
eingesetzt ohne Hoheitsabzeichen und da
sind eine Fülle solcher Gruppen
entstanden darunter auch die
wagnergruppe die sind später auch in
Syrien als Bodentruppe eingesetzt worden
weil Russland nicht mit regulären
Bodentruppen dort vor Ort war später
auch in Libyen dann in Mali
Zentralafrikanische Republik also die
jenseits der Ukraine ist diese
wagnergruppe auch zur Unterstützung von
autokratischen oder Militär projizisten
in Afrika zum Einsatz gekommen
welche Rolle hat pregorien dann als Chef
dieser Gruppe wie wie mächtig ist er und
welchen Einfluss hat er daraus
hat eine Karriere eigentlich in den 80er
Jahren als Schwerverbrecher gehabt hat
dann auch neun Jahre lang im Gefängnis
eingesessen hat dann in den 90er Jahren
sich ein ziemlich weit verzweigtes
firmenemperium aufgebaut dazu gehört
dann Catering Service deswegen ja dann
auch als Putins Koch angesehen wurde bei
der da aus Staat sind Finger
ausgerichtet hat er hatte trollfabriken
hatte Medienunternehmen Import
Exportfirmen und hat auch Baufirmen
gehabt die vor allen Dingen für das
Militär gearbeitet haben und dann eben
auch diese private militärfirma insofern
war diese wagnergruppe Teil einer
größeren Holding
Ausdruck der Kommerzialisierung von
Sicherheit der Verquickung von
Sicherheitsapparaten mit Oligarchen
macht in Russland hat man von den
sogenannten Silo Archen gesprochen also
den Silo Viki den machtministerien die
gleichzeitig oligarchische
Wirtschaftsmacht haben und dafür stand
Wagner und pregorien
wir müssen ich habe es eingangs schon
mal gesagt natürlich mit diesen
Informationen die uns jetzt gerade aus
Russland erreichen sehr vorsichtig
umgehen da ist noch nichts bestätigt
wenn wir jetzt trotzdem einmal annehmen
dass pregorien tatsächlich auf der
Passagierliste war und auch im Flieger
saß und mit abgestürzt ist würde
bedeuten die wagnertruppe hätte ihren
Chef verloren gibt es dann da jetzt ein
Machtvakuum kann diese Gruppe auch ohne
ihn weiter existieren
also erstens hat sich Russland nie
abhängig gemacht von einer einzigen
privaten militärfirma es gibt ein gutes
Dutzend davon die wagnergruppe ist jetzt
vor dem Hintergrund der Kämpfer um
bachmut und Solidar seit August letzten
Jahres sehr berühmt geworden die anderen
sind mir im Hintergrund geblieben aber
durchaus auch aktiv nach wie vor auch in
Syrien oder in anderen afrikanischen
Staaten insofern das Überleben dieses
Geschäftsmodells hängt nicht von
pregorian allein ab nach der Meuterei
vor zwei Monaten sind ja einige auch
schon zu anderen also privaten
militärfungen übergelaufen und kleiner
Teil ist bei pregorien geblieben in
Belarus Teil sag mal das
Geschäftsmodells ist auch von der
regulären Armee unternommen übernommen
wurden die eben jenseits der regulären
Soldaten sich auch noch so eine
zusätzliche reguläre bewaffnete Gruppe
zugelegt haben die dann aber mehr
steuerbar ist das Problem mit Wagner war
Zauberlehrling ist Problem für Putin er
hatte die Truppe zugelassen geschaffen
auch um Druck aufs Militär auszuüben und
die haben sich verselbstständigt und die
Meuterei hat gezeigt er muss der
staatliche Gewaltmonopol wieder
herstellen er kann also nicht diese Art
von Doppelherrschaft dauerhaft zulassen
weil die Gruppe Wagner eben auch seinen
Verteidigungsminister und
generalstaatchef immer mehr
herausgefordert hat und damit auch
Putins Autorität herausgefordert ist hat
im Prinzip musste Putin sich entscheiden
zwischen Wagner und dem
Verteidigungsminister Scholl und der hat
sich für schon gut entschieden und für
die Rassismus und gegen
aber das schon vor zwei Monaten
ich wollte gerade sagen also er hat vor
zwei Monaten es hat unser Kollege aus
Moskau am Körper ja auch gerade schon
mal gesagt auf den Marsch auf Moskau
aufgerufen er galt aber lange auch als
sehr enger Vertrauter von Putin das war
ja offenbar zuletzt dann nicht mehr ganz
so der Fall oder
ich glaube Sie sind sich von den
Persönlichkeiten her sehr ähnlich
sie haben ja auch immer ähnliche
bekanntschaftskreise und uns einmal
Geschäftsfelder in den 90er Jahren in St
Petersburg gehabt ich glaube dass sie
von von der Persönlichkeitsstruktur gar
nicht so weit auseinander liegen das
Entscheidende ist dass
Putin
das Vertrauen natürlich verloren hatte
mit dieser Meuterei vor zwei Monaten das
heißt da hatte sich pregorien direkt
gegen die kreml-führung gestellt und
hatte sozusagen
ein Machtkampf herausgefordert und da
hat in der Vergangenheit eigentlich
Putin immer eindeutig darauf reagiert
das was alle erstaunt hat bei einer Tat
das ist erstmal so ein Gentleman gegeben
hatte so eine Art von Machtteilung aber
viele haben vorher gesagt das ist nur
zeitweilige Beruhigung aber das
Schicksal von der Gruppe Wagner und von
Gregorian ist eigentlich mit diesem Pott
versucht besiegelt gewesen wir Kollegen
schon sagte wer als Verräter bezeichnet
wurde von Putin der wird liquidiert
diese Meinung vertreten tatsächlich auch
die Anhänger von Pregarten wenn man in
den telegram-kanal schaut in dem er in
der Vergangenheit seine Botschaften
verbreitet hat da wird auch von einem
gezielten Anschlag gesprochen und zwar
sei die Maschine über dem Gebiet von
quer von der Flugabwehr abgeschossen
worden das wird geschrieben in dem
Telegramm Kanal Gray Zone überprüfbar
sind diese Information natürlich bisher
nicht lassen Sie uns gerne auch noch mal
einen Blick werfen auf die Fragen die
uns von euch von ihnen die ganze Zeit
auch erreichen bei Youtube und per Mail
und zwar fragt icke wie realistisch ist
es denn dass Pregarten seinen Tod
tatsächlich nur vorgetäuscht hat halten
Sie das für ein denkbares Szenario
das halte ich eher für unwahrscheinlich
auf der anderen Seite wird es jetzt wenn
man so nach dem Vorgehen in der
Vergangenheit schließt enorm viel
Verwirrung geben es wird also ein enorm
viele verschiedene Versionen geben die
da in den russischen Medien
verbreitet werden und letztlich wenn es
selbst also diesen auftragsmot gegeben
hat zum Abschluss der Maschine dann wird
das nicht öffentlich eingestanden
sondern im Grunde genommen wird
wie schon damals beim Abschluss dieser
malaiischen Maschine über der Ukraine
werden da also vielfältige verschiedene
Gerüchte gestreut bis das Publikum
gänzlich verwirrt ist und keiner mehr
genau weiß und dann wird es irgendwann
versickern dieser dieser informations
die diese Geräuschkulisse und das wird
zu keiner Aufklärung kommen weil
letztlich müsste ja eine unabhängige
Aufklärung auch möglich sein wenn es
hier ein offiziellen Abschluss gegeben
hat dann werden wir die Wahrheit
zumindest also russischen offiziellen
Quellen nie erfahren
und da bleibt es eh noch abzuwarten was
wir zumindest von offizieller russischer
Seite hören werden eine weitere Frage
die uns erreicht hat lautet welche
Auswirkungen hat bzw hätte der Tod von
Pregarten denn auf den Kriegsverlauf
also den russischen Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine
die Gruppe Wagner ist zum Einsatz
gekommen weil sie die Schwächen der
russischen Armee im Sommer letzten
Jahres kompensieren sollte sie hatte
viele Leute mobilisieren können was in
Russland unpopulär war die Toten der
wagnergruppe konnten verborgen werden
werden die anderen sozusagen auch
sichtbar beerdigt werden müssen mussten
es war der Versuch eigentlich die
Offensive vorzuführen aber das ist der
gescheitert in der in den Kämpfen um die
Stadt braucht Mut und wir sind jetzt in
einer ganz anderen Phase des Krieges als
wenn man die in der die Gruppe Wagner
zum Einsatz gekommen ist die Russen
haben sich eingebunkert sie haben sich
auf die ukrainische Gegend Offensive
vorbereitet sie machen keine Offensive
mehr keine Städte kämpfen mehr sondern
sie sind sehr defensiv und er mit
Distanzwaffen greifen sie ukrainische
Infrastruktur und Zivilbevölkerung an
aber dieser Modus den Sie von August
Frühsommer diesen Jahres hatten für den
Stand Wagner aber jetzt sind wir in
einer anderen Etappe und da braucht auch
das russische Militär Wagner weniger als
früher
deswegen ich will die Frage nicht unter
Tisch fallen lassen die lautet wer wird
denn das Zettner von pregorsee das
Zepter tatsächlich übernehmen auch wenn
sie jetzt sagen dass die wagnertruppe
vielleicht nicht mehr die prägende Rolle
in dem Krieg hat die Sie vielleicht eins
hatte
ich denke man muss da viel breiter
reingehen man muss an die Frage rangehen
warum ist diese Parallelstrukturen gibt
also es gibt reguläre Streitkräfte es
gibt die Nationalgarde es gibt den
Geheimdienst der FSB Militärgeheimdienst
alles mit stehenden Truppen und dann
hält man sich sozusagen noch diese
egroulären daneben das macht Russland
mittlerweile seit 2014 also seit fast
zehn Jahren
dieses Modell wird meines Erachtens
weiter fortgeführt allerdings nicht mehr
mit dem mit dem Hybriden Kriegsführung
also der der Absicht ja was abstreiten
zu können sondern man wird auf diese
irregulären zurückgreifen um sie
stärker auch einmal staatlicher
Kontrolle zu unterstellen weil das
Problem bei Wagner war die waren
eigentlich die Kämpfer nicht nur
patriotisch sondern vor allen Dingen
kommerziell interessiert und motiviert
und sie hatten hohes Maß an Autonomie
und das ist zu einer Sollbruchstelle in
dem System geworden und jetzt muss man
diese Termin wieder aufheben aber diese
Parallelstrukturen werden meines
Erachtens weiter existieren
es gibt noch Informationen die aus
diesem Telegramm Kanal von pregorji an
uns rankommen der die will ich noch
gerne einmal hier vorlesen und zwar wird
da geschrieben es seien zwei Flugzeuge
der Privatarmee Wagner in der Luft
gewesen das zweite habe auf dem Flug
nach St Petersburg kehrt gemacht und
seit dem Flughafen
ostavijevo südlich von Moskau gelandet
greyzone zog die behördenversion in
Zweifel wonachine auf der Passagierliste
der ersten Maschine gestanden habe und
getötet worden sei wo genau
letztlich war dazu gibt es im Moment
keine aktuellen Informationen
es gibt auch andere Kommentare die uns
bei Youtube erreichen und zwar fragt
Mike du warst du Wien er dachte sie
dachte pregorian wäre zuletzt in Afrika
gewesen was wissen sie darüber
es gab am Montag
Videoaufnahmen von trigoshi vor allem
sag mal wüstenhintergrund und er hat
sich da also für die Unterstützung der
afrikanischen Missionen ausgesprochen
aber er kann natürlich in der
Zwischenzeit auch schon wieder
zurückgeflogen sein und der Moment in
dem das hochgestellt wurde dieses Video
muss nicht der Moment der Aufnahme
gewesen sein insofern ist das möglich
wenn man dem Argument folgt das tut und
pregorien gewisse Ähnlichkeiten haben
also Putin fliegt immer mit mehreren
Flugzeugen wenn der in der Luft ist dann
weiß keiner von außen in welchem
Flugzeug Putin jetzt eigentlich sitzt
und wenn privatins sozusagen das
Verhalten von Putin auch imitiert auch
in der Hinsicht dann ist ja auch nicht
nur mit einem Flugzeug unterwegs also
sofern wir müssen da abwarten was
dagegen spricht ist das ist wohl
Versuche von dem näheren Umfeld von
privaten gegeben hat mit ihm Kontakt
aufzunehmen und das ist seit 17 :40 Uhr
nach Lage meiner Information nicht
gelungen da ist jetzt schon relativ viel
Zeit vergangen ähm denn wenn er da in
einem anderen Flugzeug gewesen wäre und
am Leben wäre dann hätte er mit seinem
näheren Umfeld gewiss Kontakt
aufgenommen
Herr heinemann-brüder lassen sie uns
abschließend noch einmal den Blick der
User hat es gerade schon angesprochen
nach Afrika richten und zwar die
wagnertruppe ist da ja zuletzt auch sehr
aktiv gewesen in der russler für die
Russlands afrika-strategie was genau hat
die wagnertruppe da gemacht was macht
sie da und welche Rolle oder welche
Auswirkungen hat der mögliche Tod von
Pregarten auf diese Strategie Russlands
Gruppe
ist sozusagen die die Bodentruppe in
inneren Kriegen in Syrien in Libyen in
substahara Afrika sie unterstützt all
diejenigen Militärs die gegen
UN-Missionen gegen EU-Missionen gegen
die Präsenz von Frankreich oder auch der
USA in diesen Ländern sind sie
trainieren diese Putschisten sie ihr
sorgen für Sicherheit sie sind
gleichzeitig an der Ausbildung von
Bodenschätzen Beteiligten Mali zum
Beispiel Gold
oder auch seltene Metalle in der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik das heißt
sie lassen sich bezahlen für ihre
Dienste mit Boden schätzen die dann auch
über das Wagner Imperium exportiert
werden sie sind gleichzeitig auch mit
Propaganda Missionen unterwegs haben
also so Medienkampagnen für die
Putschisten organisiert sie machen
nachrichtendienstliche Tätigkeit sie
tragen dazu muss man Sanktionen umgehen
kann also sie haben relativ breites
Portfolio an Dienstleistungen die Sie
diesen Putschisten in Mali in Burkina
Faso
in Niger anbieten können sind ja auch
schon im Sudan aktiv gewesen auch in der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik in
Mosambik und so weiter
also wir gehen davon aus dass der dass
der Tod von pregorian da starke
Auswirkungen haben wird oder dass sich
das eher in Grenzen hält und man schnell
Ersatz für ihn finden wird
das ist schwer zu sagen wir sehr
ersetzbar ist und der seine Position da
einnehmen könnte ich glaube man muss
eher davon ausgehen dass die Russen auch
mit ihrer Afrika Strategien Interesse
daran haben dass sie da nicht eine
wild geworden oder sagen wir allzu
autonome Truppe haben sondern dass auch
die afrika-missionen dichter an das
Verteidigungsministerium angebunden sind
und das eben nicht nur als mal
kommerzielle sozusagen Truppe von von
von Sölden angesehen wird sondern dass
das auch als Teil der staatlichen
zusammen zwischenstaatlichen
Zusammenarbeit angesehen wird und
insofern man da auch seriöseren
Charakter haben will Problem ist nämlich
auch dass die Gruppe Wagner zum Teil auf
solche immer mordkommissionen gegangen
ist wie auch schon in der Ukraine und
das das hat den Ruf der wagnergruppe zum
Teil auch zum Beispiel in Mali
angeschlagen weil sie dann der ganze
Dörfer gelöscht haben und damit
eigentlich zum auf weiteren aufwuchs der
islamistischen Kräfte eher beigetragen
haben als dass sie als sie dass sie das
Problem besser gelöst hätten als die
EU-Mission Herrmann Guder sie haben da
vorhin schon kurz ihre Skepsis auch
geäußert aber trotzdem noch mal die
Frage selbst angenommen ist unter den
Opfern dieses Flugzeugs Absturz würden
wir denn da überhaupt eine
hundertprozentige Antwort auf diese
Frage bekommen ob er tatsächlich ums
Leben gekommen ist unter diesen
Umständen
ja irgendwann muss man natürlich
mitteilen was aus ihm geworden ist und
man wird
der Tod
als geheim Geheimnis bewahren lassen
aber das ist hier zu einer unabhängigen
Aufklärung der Ursachen dieses
Flugzeugabsturzes kommen wird das ist
mit russischen Diensten sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass es eher so wie bei
dem Mordversuch an der Wahl nie da
wurden dann auch alle möglichen Gerüchte
gestreut bis dahin dass er letztlich in
der Berliner Charité vergiftet worden
wäre also da kann man nicht von einer
Unabhängigkeit der Ermittlungsbehörden
ausgehen und jeder der das unabhängig
versucht der wird nicht lange bleiben
sagt Andreas heidemann-gröder
Politikwissenschaftler an der Uni Bonn
danke dass Sie so kurzfristig die Zeit
für uns gefunden haben und danke für
ihre ganzen Antworten und Einschätzung
genau wir sind heute Abend wieder live
gewesen und zwar weil es aktuelle
Meldung aus Russland gibt dort soll
offenbar ein Flugzeug abgestürzt sein
und mit an Bord dieses Flugzeugs soll
jetzt gewesen sein der Chef der
russischen sollten dann Trippe das sind
bisher alles ganz frische Informationen
die noch nicht verifiziert werden
konnten sie sind also deswegen mit
Vorsicht zu genießen wir uns war es
trotzdem wichtig da einmal drüber zu
sprechen und wichtige Fragen für euch zu
beantworten wenn ihr auf dem aktuellen
Stand bleiben wollt dann schaut gerne
jederzeit vorbei in unserer App ZDF
heute da findet ihr die aktuellsten
Entwicklung und danke für den Moment
fürs zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal
ciao